Up here, Alzheimer's, autoimmunity,
movement disorders, arthritis, whatever.
Name it. It all comes after this
triangle.
You don't have a chronic disease without
this triangle underneath it.
So, that means two things.
Number one, if you try to treat your
heart disease
or your cancer, your Alzheimer's, or
whatever it is, without addressing the
triangle, it ain't going to work.
And that alone
is one of the most important reasons for
the failure of modern medicine to deal
with chronic degenerative disease. Make
no mistake about it. Hopefully, it's not
Nobody is under the illusion that that's
inaccurate. The modern medical model has
presided over the the most obese, the
most cancer-ridden, the most
diabetes-ridden, the most
heart disease-filled, the sickest
culture in the history of mankind.
The modern medical model has presided
over that. Where the modern medical
model has excelled, of course, is in
surgery, emergencies,
repairing things, stitching things back
on.
What we call in the business heroic
medicine. Versus ambulatory medicine.
Ambulatory medicine is when you walk. To
ambulate is to walk. So, you walk into
the clinic, walk out of the clinic,
failure.
But the heroic side, they're amazing.
So, give credit where credit is due.
However, for the chronic degenerative
disease, there's nothing that They just
don't have the tools because
the triangle, which underlies
everything, is lifestyle, mostly food.
There's no drugs for the digestive
system. You can't take a drug to make
your digestive system better. You can
get a hide the symptoms,
but you can't take a drug to make to
make it healthy.